all my life I've known that I don't want
children after seeing this film that is
confirmed beyond the shadow of a doubt
[Music]
we need to talk about kevin stars Tilda
Swinton john c reilly and Ezra Miller
it's a story of a mother who has a son
who is pretty much the most hateful son
that you could possibly think to have
cries endlessly gets into trouble and I
don't just mean rude I mean inhuman this
kid is literally evil he's just a boy
just a sweet little boy this is a
crushing film and when I say crushing I
mean it in a good way there's certain
films that can leave you feeling very
angry upset depressed about the context
of the film and what's what takes place
in the film how it makes you feel and
it's not fun you feel angry at the film
because it made you feel that way that's
not what I'm talking about this film
will do some of those things too you'll
make you angry it will make you upset it
will disturb you and it will make you
rethink certain things see this film is
a film that people will look at
differently people will see one side of
it people see another side of it some
people hate this film I guarantee there
will be people who will probably shout
at the screen and leave in the middle
just because
doesn't mean you like it used to me good
shot comes natural because watching this
movie it's not a pleasant experience is
a difficult film to watch and the Sun
just grates on your nerve so much and
the actors who portray him particularly
Ezra Miller are very good at that
they're very good in their roles it was
meant to make you feel uneasy because
the main character played by Tilda
Swinton feels uneasy as well and she is
great in this film she is a terrific
actress who surprised too much then he's
too quiet and you see that some kind of
personal vendetta you think I'm
exaggerating she's a good example of one
of those actresses that is very much not
Hollywood not Hollywood at all however
extremely famous and she deserves it
because she is very good at her job her
job here is to make you feel for her
character and to make you understand
some of the things that she does and she
does that very well and and her
performance is just so real she's one of
those actors were as you're watching the
film you're not thinking of oh I'm
watching this actress right now it's
something in the back of your mind kind
of what you're just thinking where is
this character gonna go because her
character is so well realized and it's
not just it's not just her performance
it's very well-written film I miss
somebody
it's easy to misunderstand when you hear
it
contacts ardent not another context
some of the problems I had are the music
choices I I do not like the music
choices in the movie in my opinion the
reason a song or musical score should
accompany film is to enhance the film
never to distract or take away and for
We Need to Talk About Kevin I feel the
music really distracts I think the score
in the film by the composer those are
very good those seem to fit the movie
but the song choices I thought were
awful by far the most recommendable
thing about this movie is the
performances john c reilly is also very
good
[Music]
see some people are gonna look at this
film they're gonna overanalyze it and
they're gonna think oh he's not really
evil to the mom's imagination or
whatever I'm sorry it I just I don't
work that way if he would have just been
disciplined I mean if I talked to my
parents the way this kid gets away
talking to his mom right in front of his
dad I would have gotten slapped in the
face I would have gotten turned over the
knee I would have had handprints all
over my butt the fact that I'm so
intricately dissecting their
relationship of that family shows you
how good of a film this is in regards to
how well it's written just a sweet
that's it boys do
if you are pregnant or considering
having children do not watch this film
mm-hmm not your movie great performances
all around I'm going to give We Need to
Talk About Kevin and a - if you liked
this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck my eyes
[Music]